so I really like this this headline from
Yahoo that I just saw on Twitter the
headline is influencer says she was on a
tapas and cocaine diet to stay thin
here's why that's not healthy okay I'm
not sure if the here's why that's not
healthy bit at the end there is strictly
speaking necessary I don't know if
anyone's gonna read the first part of
that headline and say themselves oh well
you know that sounds like a great idea
I'll just subsist on little appetizer
dishes and cocaine and you know that
sounds like a great diet and then they
read the second part and say oh never
mind says here it's not healthy
shoot but let me click and find out why
it's not healthy though that's the thing
all right a Democratic congresswoman
from Hawaii named Tulsi Gabbard has
really impressed me actually doesn't
happen often with Democrats but she
wrote an op-ed in the hill defending
religious liberty and calling out her
fellow Democrats for their attacks on it
she doesn't use their names specifically
but she's talking about senators Kamala
Harris and mazie Hirono because they've
essentially been trying to impose a
religious test on a Catholic judicial
nominee named Brian Bowe sure they're
upset that Bo sure is Catholic and
they're especially upset that he's a
member of the Knights of Columbus
now Hirono who you may remember as
somehow managing to be the most
insufferable democrat during the
Kavanagh hearings but she wants Bosher
to leave the Knights of Columbus she's
very concerned he's got to leave the
Knights of Columbus if he wants to be a
a judge and he should also recuse
himself from any case that deals with
issues that the Knights of Columbus have
taken a position on not any case of the
Knights of Columbus are specifically
involved in which of course in that case
he should recuse them but no any case
that deals with issues that the Knights
well here's the thing the Knights of
Columbus they're a Catholic organization
so their positions are just going to be
whatever the Catholic Church's positions
are so and the Catholic Church has a
position
on many different subjects especially
the big most controversial subsite
subjects like abortion and marriage and
and those sorts of things so what she's
really saying is what she you know she
might be saying Knights of Columbus what
she's really saying though is he should
recuse himself from any case involving
issues that the Catholic Church has
taken a position on which is another way
of saying you can't be a judge if you're
Catholic let me read a little bit from
gabbard's Hill peace and because this is
really solid stuff she says while I
oppose the nomination of Brian Bosher to
the u.s. district court at Nebraska I
stand strongly against those who are
fomenting religious bigotry citing as
disqualifiers Bowe shares Catholicism
and his affiliation with the Knights of
Columbus if Bo sure is unqualified
because of his Catholicism
and his affiliation with the Knights of
Columbus then President John F Kennedy
and the Liberal Lion of the Senate
Senate Ted Kennedy would have been
unqualified for the same reasons article
6 of the US Constitution clearly states
that there shall be no religious test
for any seeking to serve in public
office no Americans should be told that
his or her public service is unwelcome
because quote the dogma lives loudly
within you as Senator Dianne Feinstein
said to Amy Cohn e Barrett during her
confirmation hearings in 2017 to serve
as US Circuit Court judge in the Seventh
Circuit while I absolutely believe in
the separation of church and state as a
necessary to the health of our nation no
Americans should be asked to renounce
his or her faith or membership in a
faith-based service organization in
order to hold public office the party
that works so hard to convince people
that Catholics and Knights of Columbus
like Al Smith and John F Kennedy could
be good Catholics and good public
service that shows an alarming disregard
of its own history in making such
attacks very well put and this is coming
from a Democrat okay it's very rare you
get this from a Democrat which is why
other Democrats and liberals are not
very pleased with Gabbard and have come
out and made that clear
coming to the defense of Hirono and
harris jill philip philipovich he was a
leftist writer with apparently a big
pretty big following on line she had
this to say on Twitter she says tulsi
gabbard is accusing female senators of
anti-catholic bigotry for rightly
questioning a judicial nominees
membership in an extreme right-wing
anti-choice anti LGBT all-male
organization Gabbard is not a
progressive she's a fraud so if you
stand up now Jill's making it very clear
and there are a lot of leftists who
agree with her
if you stand for religious liberty then
you're a front you're not a real
progressive you're a fraud and I might
actually agree with her on that that if
you stand for religious liberty you're
not a real leftist or a real progressive
by today's progressive standards which
is a good thing
the only difference is I see that as a
very positive thing now Jill says that
the Knights of Columbus
apparently Harris and her Ono feel the
same way the Knights of Columbus are an
extreme right-wing group if you aren't
familiar the Knights of Columbus is a
group of men who get together and they
pray and they do charity drives and they
do things like that okay I mean it is
the most unthreatening group of people
that you could possibly imagine this is
one of the main groups you know around
Christmastime where you see those boxes
the people are collecting toys doing toy
this is one of the main groups that does
the stoy drives around Christmastime
collecting toys for poor kids that's
what the Knights of Columbus does yet
they are now an extremist group as if as
if the Knights of Columbus are wearing
literal suits of armor and you know
charging into battle with swords and
spears and that sort of thing so how
clearly there's stuff about the Knights
of Columbus it is it is again this is
just very thinly veiled anti-catholic
bigotry that's that's really what what
that's about the Knights of Columbus
when it comes down to it these are just
Catholic men who get together and and
you know have a you know fraternity and
and as I said do they pray and they do
charity work and that sort of thing so
if you've got a problem with them what
you really have a problem with is
Catholicism so how do we count for this
how do we account for this just kind of
open anti-christian bigotry on the left
well we're now they're they're so
straightforward about it they're so
blatant it's like they're not even
trying to disguise it well there's a
very obvious answer here of course the
left hates Christianity because of the
moral message of Christianity and that
moral message makes them feel bad it
cramps their style it interferes with
their relativistic approach to things
and that's the main reason why they hate
it which is pretty obvious but I think
there's something else as well there's
also a fundamental lack of understanding
on the left when it comes to religion
and that is you know when when a leftist
thinks of bigotry they think of a person
who hates someone else for that other
person's identity if you hate someone
because of their identity then you're a
bigot except the problem is people on
the left they don't recognize religious
affiliation as an identity they just
don't see it that way they can't
understand how a person's religion is a
not only a part of their identity but
any religious person will tell you it's
not only a part of their identity it is
the most central crucial important part
of their identity now you notice that we
say this about religious bigotry and how
they don't care
religious bigotry yet they do talk about
Islamophobia all the time so they are
worried about that kind of religious
bigotry but that's because they
associate Islam with non-white people
and so when they're worried about
Islamophobia what they're really worried
about in their mind is sort of an anti
Arab bias so they see that as entirely
ethnic and racial that's why they care
about that if Muslims were mostly white
they wouldn't care about Islamophobia at
all and that's why that's one another
one of the reasons why they don't care
about anti-christian bias is because
they see Christianity as a white thing
which of course is ridiculous
Christianity was born in the Middle East
the majority of Christians in the world
are actually not white I mean there are
a whole lot of Christians in Africa
there are a whole lot of Christians in
South and Central America there are
plenty of Christians in Asia it is not a
white invention and it's not a white
thing it is a universal thing but it is
also a choice you know you have to
choose to to to accept this faith to
accept the gospel you have to choose
that but that doesn't make it any less a
part of your identity
if anything it makes it more a part of
your identity or at least it makes it a
more important part of your identity
because it's not something that you're
just born with it's not just an accident
of nature it's it's something that you
pursue and find and organize your life
around and
that's why that's why it's not as it's
not as simple as saying oh well you know
it's okay to hate someone for their or
to hate someone's religion because they
choose that they could easily choose a
different religion I mean these are
people on the left they're these are the
ones who are who are constantly talking
about the the value of choice right
they're supposed to be pro-choice
they're supposed to be they're supposed
to see choice as this wonderful
beautiful thing well okay I agree
religion is a choice and that is what
makes it such a crucial thing talk to a
person's identity staying in the realm
of religion my friend Paul bought the
daily wire has an interesting piece on
the site right now about a megachurch
pastor who has announced his
congregation that the Ten Commandments
no longer apply to Christians okay
here's what Paul writes he says popular
mega church pastor Andy Stanley of North
Point ministries says Christians need to
stop erecting monuments to the 10
commandments because they apparently no
longer apply to Christians which is
completely false in a piece posted
irrelevant magazine on Monday pastor
Stanley said that since the Ten
Commandments come from the Old Covenant
Christians should stop erecting
monuments dedicated to them Stanley says
if we're going to create a monument to
stand as a testament to our faith
shouldn't it at least be a monument of
something that actually applies to us
participants in the New Covenant that's
Christians are not required to obey any
of the commandments found in the first
part of their Bibles participants in the
new covenants are expected to obey the
single command
Jesus issued as part of his new covenant
as I have loved you so you must love one
another he continued but how many times
have you seen Christians trying to post
the text of the Sermon on the Mount at a
public place or the all-encompassing
commandment Jesus gave us Stanley goes
on to say that this commandment from
Christ is a replacement for everything
in the existing list including the Big
Ten just as his new covenant replaced
the Old Covenant Jesus
new commandment replaced all the old
Commandments Stanley contended Stanley
also among the fact that too many
congregations placed too much emphasis
on the old covenant Jesus was
foreshadowed in the old covenant he did
not come to extend it
dear Christian reader why why why would
we even be tempted to reach back beyond
the cross to borrow from a covenant that
was temporary and inferior to the
covenant established for us at Calvary
ok first of all I'd be perfectly fine
with with putting the text of the Sermon
on the Mount anywhere I think that'd be
great
now a monument with the entire text of
the Sermon on the Mount might be that's
that would be kind of a big Monument
it's because it's a pretty lengthy
sermon but I'm perfectly fine with that
so that's the only part of what you just
read that I agree with that yeah look
let's put the the Sermon on the Mount
let's make monuments of the Sermon on
the Mount the rest of it though is just
is just it is bad exegesis it is bad
hermeneutics it is bad theology it is
bad everything it's heresy it's
stupidity it's the kind of thing that
you could maybe excuse a six-year-old
for saying before his Sunday School
teacher corrects him and this guy
pastors a church not just any Church but
a big a mega church with thousands of of
adherents and he writes best-selling
books and yet he has not the most basic
theological understanding of his own
religion because you know basically
anyone could be a megachurch pastor you
just you just just walk it and you say
Here I am
I'm gonna tell you about Jesus and
people go and they sit and they listen
to this guy pontificate and they imagine
they're doing something religiously you
know fulfilling or edifying this is just
this guy's opinion he's just given you
his opinion and it's a really bad stupid
wrong opinion on top of that he has no
business being a pastor um where to even
begin with this Jesus is not a
replacement and the commandments he
gives us are not replacement a
replacement is something you put in
place because the old thing is broken
it's like God changed his mind and said
ah you know never mind with all that
let's do this instead no Jesus came to
fulfill the old covenant fulfill it not
abolish it not replace it he says that
himself he clarifies this exact point
it's right there in the book Matthew
5:17 look it up I did not come to
abolish but to fulfill there's a
difference and and there's this as well
you shall love the Lord God with all
your heart and with all your soul and
with all your mind this is the great and
first commandment and a second is like
it you shall love your neighbor as
yourself he's caught he calls these
commandments greatest great he does not
say they're the only ones he doesn't say
that they replace the old ones don't
kill don't steal honor your parents
don't covet don't take the Lord's name
it apparently pastor Andy Staley thinks
that the Stanley thinks that okay well I
guess so what we can still we don't have
to honor our parents anymore we could
take the Lord's name in vain
no Jesus
someone Jesus said Jesus doesn't doesn't
replace those he doesn't do away with
them he doesn't say yeah forget about
all that in fact again he specifically
clarifies this point in that verse I
just read read one more sentence over he
says on these two commandments depend
all the law and the prophets
now why would he be talking about that
that the law and the prophets
depend on these two commandments that he
just gave if the law and the prophets
are now irrelevant what he's saying is
that the moral laws of the Old Testament
including the Ten Commandments rest upon
these Commandments that he gave in these
Commandments are this is a commandment
of love so he's saying love is the
foundation and and the law and the
prophets depend upon are rooted in are
founded upon love by the way.this see
here's the difference between what I'm
saying now and what Pastor Stanley is
saying I'm not giving like my
interpretation or my opinion about it
I'm just telling you what what I'm just
telling you what the book says that's
all I'm just giving you what the book
says and I'm saying if we have to choose
between siding with what Jesus says in
the Gospels or siding with Andy Stanley
you know I'm going with Jesus personally
that's just me the moral laws of the Old
Testament hold okay the moral laws hold
forever and all time that this is just
basic Christian theology I mean it's
again this is Sunday school when you're
seven years old type of stuff there are
there are different kinds of laws in the
Old Testament and you do have to
distinguish between them so you have
moral laws decreed by God and then you
have ceremonial laws like the stuff
about mixed fabrics and dietary
restrictions and so on now those we are
no longer bound to uphold those are not
you
mutable eternal fundamentally moral laws
and this is also something that Paul
spends a lot of time now I'm talking
about st. Paul not Paul boy from daily
walk this is something that that st.
Paul spends a lot of time and his
epistles explaining but all yet that's
the thing all you have to go is just
read the text just go read the text of
yourself it this stuff has been has been
clarified it's been settled and it's
amazing to me I don't know how I could
still be amazed by but but it's amazing
to me that people could still be
confused about this stuff when you could
just go pick up the book and read it not
only are people confuse but pastors are
confused have you ever read Paul pick
him up sometime and it's not that the
epistles aren't that long aren't that
many of them also if you read church
history okay if you read the history of
early Christianity if you read about the
kind of things that the Church Fathers
were dealing with in the 1st 2nd and 3rd
centuries you'll find that heretics like
Stanley they're not even doing us the
favor of inventing new heresies ok
they're just cooking up old ones so they
don't even have the creativity to come
up with new ones and at least that would
keep make it a little bit interesting to
have this conversation there was a
garden guy named Marcion he was a false
teacher a leader of a heretical
Christian sect in the early second
century that was 1,900 years ago and he
taught what Stanley is basically saying
here
he said the Old Testament doesn't apply
to us he also taught that the Old
Testament God was a tyrant and a despot
and a completely different god from the
god of the New Testament
now Stanley doesn't go that far that's
true but the crux is the same ok so this
this is basically Marcion ism repackaged
to reheated and made a little bit more
palatable because as I said the guy
Marcy in 1900 years ago he was just he
was he had open contempt for the Old
Testament and for that God and you know
he basically spat upon it Stanley isn't
going to go that far but the but their
basic point is exactly the same which is
this stuff doesn't apply to us it's not
our book this you know
Stanley's church should be empty now I
mean after after writing this article
his church should be completely empty if
you go to his church you should be
running for the hills at this point if
you keep going just realize that you're
you're not going to a church okay you're
not going for anything that could be
considered a church service you're going
to just sit down and hear some dudes
opinion an opinion which is disconnected
divorced from Christian theology and the
text of scripture so this dude is just
inventing his new thing that's all you
he's coming up with his new kind of
religion and if you go to his church
then you're yeah you're you're a member
of that religion that he's inventing
let's call it Stanley ISM okay this is
not Christianity this is Stanley ISM and
you have every right to be a member of
Stanley ISM if that's if it appeals to
you in America First Amendment you have
every right to join that religion but I
just feel like you should know it's not
the Christian religion because all you
have to do is read the text read the
scripture read a little bit about the
history of your own religion or of your
former religion and you're gonna find
that these things have been dealt with I
mean they've been dealt with it's
there's really no no real controversy
here it's very clear all right what else
real quick
California is looking at a ban on paper
receipts
apparently they handled the straws and
now they're going over to the receipts
now all I want to say about this
is I'm the same as anyone else I get
annoyed by receipts like you go to you
go to Rite Aid or something and you buy
a soda and a pack of gum and they give
you a receipt
that's this huge five mile long scroll
right and it's completely ridiculous but
this is and everybody's annoyed by that
and it is it does seem like I'm not much
of an environmentalist but sometimes
when I get those receipts I do think to
myself I mean did we really have to kill
a tree for this seems like sort of a
waste but this is an example the reason
I bring this up is this is an example
like with the the plastic straw thing
but even more so with this this is an
example of the government trying to
solve a problem that the market is
already in the process of solving
because while it's true that you could
still go to places and get these
absurdly long receipts more and more
places are moving away from paper
receipts and they're doing the digital
receipt and I have found just my
anecdotal experience it's more and more
common now when you go to a place that
they'll actually ask you do you want a
receipt and you can say no and then they
won't give you one it used to be back in
the day they just gave a receipt to
everybody without asking so people are
moving away from receipts they're doing
the digital receipts and 10 or 15 years
from now paper receipts won't exist so
we're already heading in that direction
without government involvement all the
government has to do is nothing all it
needs to do is just sit back and say
well this problems being solved so we
don't even need we don't even need to
argue about whether or not this is a
real problem or whether or not it
matters that it doesn't that's not the
point
because it's a it's an issue that is
already being addressed naturally by the
the by the marketplace but then what
happens is that bureaucrats stick their
noses in it and what could have been a
very natural and normal transition from
one thing to another now becomes
complicated and expensive and it
involves regulation
and laws and all of it completely
unnecessary
all right something to think about over
the weekend we'll leave it there have a
great weekend and enjoy watching playoff
football over the weekend I will not be
watching I retire from watching football
after my Ravens lost in a heartbreaker
last weekend and I'm just it's happened
too many times and I'm giving up I you
know I'm looking for a new sport so if
any any suggestions I've been looking
for a new sport to watch because I'm
done with football I can't take it
anymore I can't take the heartbreak so
you know I'm thinking something like
yeah I watch competitive bass fishing a
little bit I'm thinking maybe I'll
invest myself more in that soccer maybe
well that's not really a sport but you
know I'm looking for something else
besides football but anyone who is
watching it hope you enjoy it and I'll
talk to you next week
Godspeed